that kind of magic would work in here
harry potter fans disagree on a lot of
different things
but one of the subjects everyone seems
to agree on
is that prisoner of azkaban is one of if
not
the best harry potter movie but why is
that if you are a harry potter fan
you will certainly have your favorite
character book
movie magical moment and of course
hogwarts house
there seemingly isn't a right or
conclusive answer to the question
which is the best harry potter book
there is a movie that is arguably
universally seen as the best movie
because a lot of the details we love
from the books don't always make it to
the big screen
it leaves space for one movie to be the
chosen one and
universally adored and in the case of
harry potter fans
that is prisoner of azkaban so what
makes prisoner of azkaban so popular
and why is it rated as the best harry
potter movie of all time
reveal your secrets
the world built in harry potter is so
fleshed out and so absorbing that fans
have flocked to the magical world for
decades with everyone sharing a strong
opinion
on one particular facet this means that
every fan
also has their favorite outing in the
series for one reason or another
people love the first two novels
philosopher stone and chamber of secrets
because they are fantastical but lighter
and more youthful in turn
why is it always me others like prisoner
of azkaban because it sets a new
direction for the series
with a slightly darker and more adult
tone
goblet of fire is exceptionally popular
as it really delves into the culture of
the wizarding world
and a look at the quidditch world cup
the tri-wizard tournament
and an inclusion of more fantastical
beasts and
of course the return of the dark lord
although
seemingly no one liked the way
dumbledore said
which was described as calm in the book
others
like order of the phoenix and the
half-blood prince as the tone was even
more serious as well as the loss of our
favorite characters such as dumbledore
and sirius
and of course deathly hallows is always
popular as it brought the whole series
to a head in a frantic
and action-packed way one of the major
criticisms the harry potter movies get
is that they usually leave
a lot of content from the novels out due
primarily
to time and budget constraints however
quran somehow got away with it
and this can be attributed to a number
of reasons i want to try to tell the
movie
with a style what was as fluid as
possible azkaban stays very true to the
books
in terms of the major character story
lines and arcs which was done in a pov
type format
where the events that happened to
characters like harry and hermione are
kept
whereas moments that don't advance their
stories can hit the cutting room floor
this is vital as azkaban is lauded for
its inventive and clever storyline
one in which harry and co may save the
day we see the heroes win
as buckbeak is saved the dementors are
defeated and
sirius escapes but this doesn't mean
they end up on top
as peter escapes sirius is still an
outlaw and
lupin is forced to leave his job causing
harry to lose two of his closest allies
so now i'll say goodbye harry i feel
sure we'll meet again sometime
and an important connection to his
father in terms of story
it's somewhat a bottle episode in the
series as the major storyline
accelerates in goblet of fire with
voldemort's return
but that doesn't mean azkaban isn't
vital to the series
[Music]
another way quran gets away with his
streamlining is that he makes the world
entirely his own such as the talking
heads on the night bus
[Music]
but he also manages to keep it in line
with not only rowling's vision
but elements of columbus's first two
movies azkaban took place before some of
quran's more visceral work like
roma children of men and gravity but he
was still a red-hot director
after his movie itu mama tambien and
certainly knew his way around a camera
he was apparently eager to work on a big
franchise movie
so when given the keys to the harry
potter franchise he was not throwing
away his
shot quran made the world feel lived in
and fleshed out as he really drew the
audience into the land of witchcraft and
wizardry
taken more seriously their craft to
explore
emotional territories that they hadn't
explored before it feels like a perfect
blend of the real and the spectacular a
down-to-earth story of a boy at school
but with the potential to be epic and
grandiose quran's use of imagery and
cinematography is stunning
such as a winter at hogwarts and a trip
to hogsmeade
and certainly added to the fancifulness
of the world that we saw in columbus's
movies but quran wasn't afraid to change
the tone and make it more
adult and somewhat darker quran captured
the good
and the bad of the world and the use of
visual aesthetic and color palette
captures this the movie then reflects
the tonal shift that happens in the
novels which also moves to a slightly
darker stance than its forbearers quran
does a great job of implementing this
shift
but keeping what made us love the series
already
yes all of your books yeah it's all
upstairs
he also does a great job in focusing on
the human elements as well as the
magical ones
dumbledore is just slightly different
than before
is a little bit more playful quran's
style
and form of storytelling wasn't just
loved by the fans
but by the studio who adopted this
method for the rest of the series
azkaban didn't just reinvent the wheel
but set the formula for the rest of the
movies to come
and is comparable to what goldfinger did
for the bond franchise
goldfinger set the archetype of a huge
majority of the movies to come
the cool car the gadgets being captured
by the enemy to get undercover
azkaban does a similar thing with the
pov format and that is the structure
used throughout
we also see a more consistent visual
aesthetic throughout the series post
azkaban
particularly with the sweeping
establishing shots of the hogwarts
grounds
the use of costume design and styling
also flesh out the world
we crafted costumes that they were in a
more contemporary way
for example sirius black's outfit is
tatty and worn just like the character
and is also reminiscent of a prison
outfit you would see
worn during the second world war quran
also asked the actors to wear their more
natural clothing and to wear the school
uniform like they would wear it which is
why we see more loosely knotted ties
and untucked dress shirts but as well as
the practical effects such as costume
and quran's own aesthetic the use of
visual effects
is incredible cgi can make or break a
film
but it is perfectly used in azkaban
characters like buckbeak were
brilliantly executed
say hello to buckbeat with us endearing
ourselves to the character
while the dementors are terrifying
without being too
scary and almost exactly how they were
described in the novel
in terms of visuals and visual
storytelling it is arguably the best in
the series
and not just because it set the
standards and the tone that will be
emulated in the rest of the series but
because of quran's
ingenuity behind a camera but it's
complicated
is it strong azkaban is the beginning of
the series venturing into the more
mature content and this is seen in
harry's growth
from the get-go we know harry is a kind
smart and exceptionally brave person
he'll never be gone not as long as those
who remain are loyal to him
but we were yet to see elements of his
true magical ability
in azkaban we start to see harry step
into his shoes as the chosen one
using his powerful patronus charm to
vanquish the dementors and save himself
and his godfather sirius while it was
undoubtedly
sad that a desperate harry wouldn't be
reunited with his father
who he believed was using the stag
patronus it did show us that harry was
stepping up as a wizard as well as
sharing a deep connection with james but
it wasn't just
harry who pushed the plot forward but of
course his trusted and whipped smart
companion hermione who had a great and
empowering plot arc for herself as well
and her story throughout the movie was
extremely engaging for fans
also let's face it the moment she
punched malfoy was worth the price of
admission alone
that felt good not good brilliant
it also delved further into the magical
world with the time travel and
non-linear plot line reminiscent of the
likes of pulp fiction
everything cleverly meets at the end and
there are subtle hints and tidbits
scattered throughout that nod to how the
movie will end
we see plot points happening from dual
perspectives but instead of being
repetitive it is engaging and still
immensely satisfying to the viewer it is
expertly crafted
and none of the cuts quran made impacted
this this makes the movie's climax very
satisfying
even if it isn't quite the happily ever
after we would have liked it to have
been
with there being some horribly
heartbreaking moments as well as some
moments of pure joy
one of the most emotional plot lines is
of course that of the titular character
other than harry
the prisoner of azkaban himself sirius
black
only one would die tonight we see sirius
as a husk of a man
a life lost robbed by a man who he
thought was his friend and spending a
majority of his life in azkaban for a
crime he didn't commit
the murder of his best friend but there
is a ray of hope there
in hindsight his reunion with lupine is
endearing and after the twist
is revealed sirius adopts the role of
harry's pseudo-father figure and
provides a patriarchal figure that harry
has so desperately craved
james and lilly made me your godfather
azkaban is also a movie that continues
to expand the mythos of the harry potter
world we see an inclusion of more
fantastical elements
such as the time turner hermione uses
the marauders map which is an important
plot device and holds importance
throughout the series
where they are what they're doing every
minute of every day brilliant
an introduction to hogsmeade as well as
other important locations that will make
a later return
such as the shrieking shack and the
three broomsticks
we also see a number of fantastical
beasts added primarily buckbeak
and the monster book which serves as the
prelude to the fantastic beasts series
we also see the expansion of hogwarts
classes with divination brilliantly
introduced through emma thompson's zany
performance as professor trelawney the
future
we are introduced to further magical
abilities and curses with sirius black
and peter pettigrew being an animagus
while remus
lupin is cursed as a werewolf also their
true identities are cleverly coded in
their
names with remus being a reference to
the founders of rome
romulus and remus who were raised by
wolves and lupin is the french word for
wolf like sirius is also a reference to
the star constellation which is also
known as the big dog
and black is well the color looks so
like your father overall the movie has
a lot going for it it is one of the best
and most popular books
a great story a deep world a brilliant
director
sensational visuals and outstanding
performances and
all of these elements together add up to
arguably the best harry potter movie
at the end of the day though it is still
subjective and the quality between the
movies is nominally close
and undoubtedly people will rightly
dispute the claim that this is the best
harry potter movie do you agree that
azkaban is the best in the series
do you think azkaban did a good job of
imagining the wizarding world
or did another movie do it best do you
wish quran had done another
harry potter movie let us know in the
comments below and make sure to
subscribe to the channel for
everything magical
you